so here we are today at a public library
and i know what you're thinking ben
haven't you read all the books there
already of course i have but that's not
why we're here my producers have given
me a stack of cards they have a bunch of
terms on them having to do with the
government i have to explain these to
very very small children in a fashion
that kids can understand so we'll find
out how this is going to go this video
is sponsored by our friends over at
conserva kids
[Music]
hey guys
how's it going
wow you're very well-behaved children
all right so i'm supposed to teach you
about things today so get ready yay yay
i've seen my mom um look at him on
facebook she said he was a very smart
guy do you think he is well now that
i've met him maybe freedom okay freedom
definition oh yeah give me definition go
for it america definition of freedom's
america okay that's that's sexual okay i
kind of like that i'm with you murica
okay so
freedom is the
not the ability to do whatever you want
freedom is the ability to make good
choices and have those pay off a lot of
people kind of think that freedom is you
get to do what you want if you want to
run into a tree that's freedom
yeah exactly you shouldn't eat people
like that you don't have freedom to eat
people
isn't bad i forgot what that's called
it's called cannibalism my mom and dad
told me i was gonna meet ben shapiro and
did you know who he was
nope government
okay so who has an idea about government
go for it i don't
government is what takes all of your
money and gives you very little in
return that's not true okay that that's
kind i mean it's kind of true it depends
on the kind of government
yeah that is what taxes are for but but
taxes are theft children the reality is
that government is necessary so that
people don't
hurt each other so that people don't
murder each other right so people don't
eat people that's right you do need a
government to prevent people from eating
people the constitution who knows
something about the constitution anybody
heard of the constitution anybody heard
of the constitution
okay so the constitution okay the
constitution is that is the document
that lays out the list of rules for what
the government can do and what the
government cannot do so the declaration
of independence is 1776 so right as
we're founding the country right as the
founding fathers are founding the
country in the revolutionary war we
fought a war against great britain in
what was that
okay maybe you do know a lot
fast yeah i do talk fast but you guys
can keep up you're you're you're young i
do run pretty fast i'm sure you do
let me tell you i don't worry about
talking too fast with kids because my
kids wipe me out my kids tire me out hey
the president
oh okay oh who knows who the president
is right now
biden yeah
joe
that's right unfortunately
i'm with you
unfortunately
yeah
[Music]
taxes
okay do you guys like taxes or fees that
you have to pay for your houses well
yeah
there are there is in air conditioning
and solar right you have to pay taxes on
like everything yeah
everything else
not on your income in florida because
florida's amazing
right so
taxes are the government takes a part of
the money that you spend or the money
that you earn or the property value of
your house
mostly yes i mean they're supposed to
spend it on things like the police
they're not supposed to spend it on just
random projects or silly things that
they have in their head and they tend to
spend it on kind of silly things very
often but as you get older you will
realize how little you like taxes taxes
are very very
all annoying
let's see what else
quantitative easing
wow who put this one in here
all right are we really gonna do this we
can we could do this okay so yeah i know
i'm with you
the reason that they're laughing is
because this is super duper complicated
you know what a dollar is right you'll
use dollars before how about monopoly
money have you guys ever played monopoly
right okay
if you guys went to the store with
monopoly money could you buy anything no
no you couldn't why not
because it's not real money there is an
agency of the federal government is
called the federal reserve okay the
federal reserve controls how many
dollars are out there if they just print
a bunch of dollars and then they just
give you those dollars it turns out they
didn't make you rich all that happened
is that your dollar
now doesn't buy as many things if the
federal if the federal reserve just
makes a thousand dollars and gives it to
you and gives it to everybody you can't
buy an ice cream bar with a dollar
anymore now the ice cream bar is gonna
cost like a thousand dollars okay that's
what quantitative easing is can you
explain to me the concept of
quantitative easing go
i forgot
so guys you just learned more than you
will in all of college about how the
government works so one of the questions
that i frequently get asked is how do i
talk to my own children about
conservative values and the things that
matter and my answer is conserva kids
conserva kids brings you books like home
of the brave for example in which they
discuss things like american values and
american history they're beautifully
illustrated they're really well written
and they have values that you can feel
comfortable sharing with your children
which is the most important thing
there's so many forces out there that
are seeking to twist what kids think
there's so many people out there who
want your kids to believe things that
they really shouldn't believe who want
to take control of your child's
education away from you not so with
conservatives conservatives is the way
that you can teach your kids about the
stuff that matters they bring you all
sorts of beautiful books they have a
great variety a great selection check
them out today at theconservakids.com
shapiro that's
theconservakids.com you get 15 off when
you use code 15 ben again they just make
great materials they're safe for all
your cause not just safe they're they're
virtuous for you to get for your kids
the conserva kids.com that's the
conserva kids.com shapiro 15 off with
code 15 ben
okay go for it um what do you think
about like superstars and athletes
talking about politics so everybody in
the country gets to talk about whatever
they want to talk about but athletes and
superstars generally don't know anything
about what they're talking about when it
comes to politics when lebron james says
things that doesn't mean he knows things
yeah will you ever be a president you
know all the presidents are now 100
years old right like joe biden is really
really old joe biden is 79 years old i'm
38 which to you guys seems like super
old right like like no okay good that's
true
my dad is 48. i'll wait until my kids
are grown up i don't wanna i would never
run for office while i have little kids
because i wanna be home with my kids my
kids are super cute i wanna spend like a
lot of time with them when's ben gonna
admit that he's gonna run for president
if he wanted to be president he would
probably be it tomorrow but he just
talks about it raise your hand if you
want trump to be president
[Music]
oh that's nice of you why are the people
angry at the government why are people
angry at the government because
sometimes the government tells us to do
stuff the government shouldn't tell us
to do do you think homeschooling will
ever be banned uh not in florida so i
think that there will be places that try
to stop homeschooling i come from a
state called california where where
where monsters roam in the streets and
garbage is strewn everywhere it's it's a
horror escape no i'm joking they don't
actually have have real monsters but
it's a really poorly like the way that
they run the state is really bad they
have lots of crime they have high taxes
do you think there is a monster right
exactly i came here because florida is
amazing guys you're so lucky to be
growing up in florida florida's amazing
america is the best but florida's really
hot what does the government do what
does the government do okay so there's
various kinds of government there's your
local government like where you live and
then there's the state government like
the state of florida and then there's
the federal government they all do
different things so your local
government they do the police and they
do the firefighting and then there's the
state government the state government
decides for example how money goes to
your local public school for example or
how taxes get paid and how roads get get
made and all that then there's the
federal government the federal
government the constitution says what
the federal government can do make sure
that there's an army and a navy and an
air force and that they are able to
protect us against people who'd want to
attack the united states that's the
biggest thing the federal government
does yeah do you think biden actually
follows his own law i think that biden
kind of makes up the rules as he goes i
don't think unfortunately he cares very
much about the rules for being president
i think he just tries to do whatever he
can do and then
he hopes that nobody stops him which is
not a very good way of being president
and that's why the founders were really
smart the founders created a system
where there are people who can stop you
if you break the rules which is really
important
do you think china purposefully caused
the pandemic
i think that china purposefully covered
up a pandemic it probably started in a
laboratory in china and then it got
released and then
they pretended that it was not their
fault and they didn't know what was
going on and they lied a lot and then it
got out and killed a lot of people do
you think the supreme poor will overturn
roe versus wade
[Laughter]
um
wow um
i think the supreme court
will
not overturn roe vs weight unfortunately
i have a feeling that the supreme court
is going to
change the rules of roe versus wade but
that doesn't mean they're going to throw
it out completely they're going to do
what they always do and they're going to
be uh confusing about it who is your
favorite democrat wow that is a
difficult question i know right a lie a
live a democrat who's alive
right now joe manchin senator joe
manchin from west virginia is my current
favorite democrat he's preventing joe
biden from doing a lot of bad things do
you think we can have a stable
government again
um i mean i think that the government is
still pretty stable is the truth we
should be grateful to live in a country
where the government is this stable the
truth is that if you look at history and
if you look at all other countries there
are a lot of countries that really don't
have a stable government and it's really
difficult we're so lucky to live in this
country we really are so as much as we
have problems here in the united states
this is still a fabulous fabulous
country and we're all we should all
really be grateful to to live here and
that i guess is the is the thing that i
would say all you guys you guys are
you're going to live like for a super
long time and you're going to get to see
all sorts of amazing things happen in
the country and the most important thing
to remember is the harder you work the
better your life is going to be the
better the decisions you make the more
responsible you are the more you help
other people the better your life is
going to be in this country which is the
best country in the world if you make
great decisions you're going to have an
unbelievably awesome life you're going
to make a huge difference in the world
you can make the world a better place
what's that thing on your head oh good
question okay so this is yamaka jews and
christians believe in the in the same
god uh we just have slightly different
beliefs about the kind of stuff that we
have to do that god says that we have to
do so what this means is that orthodox
jews jews who who keep a lot of
commandments we keep this on our head
right in the bible when it talks about
the israelites that's the jews so the
jews eventually uh you know now we're
their descendants so we keep the the
yamaka on our head to remind us to that
god is around us at all times so we
should make good decisions basically all
righty guys well you can go like enjoy
your day now because it's all over so
you're good thank you guys it's great to
meet all of you
if you want to take some of these kids
home i have three of my own so more
children in my house
no they've got parents i feel like their
parents should keep them which is
tougher talking to kids about government
or explaining government to democrats oh
by far it's more difficult to explain
governments democrats because they're
they're so certain about the things that
they know and those things are just
wrong whereas kids just don't know
things and you can actually explain them
to them are you more or less hopeful for
the future i'm way more hopeful for the
future than than before i did this
because those kids are smarter than the
people that we have in congress
currently i only came today because i
thought knowles was gonna be here